en vídeos anteriores sobre congruencia
de triángulos hablamos de porque el
criterio lado lado ángulo no puede
usarse para determinar la congruencia
entre triángulos pero lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es mostrarte un caso
en donde si funciona y este caso es
cuando estamos trabajando con triángulos
rectángulos es decir cuando este ángulo
en particular es de 90 grados muy bien
es decir este ángulo es recto en cuyo
caso este primer lado sería la
hipotenusa aunque vamos a ponerlo así
nada más sería la hipotenusa y este otro
lado pues tendría que ser un cateto
tendría que ser un cateto verdad
entonces es por esto que en ocasiones
llamaremos a este criterio como
congruencia hipotenusa cateto lo voy a
escribir este sería la congruencia
hipotenusa
hipotenusa cateto y luego con los mismos
colores ok
hipotenusa cateto muy bien y recordemos
cuando estamos hablando de hipotenusa
pues en realidad inmediatamente tenemos
que pensar en triángulos rectángulos
verdad sólo tendremos hipotenusa en
triángulos rectángulos y para tener una
idea de por qué dos rectángulos serán
congruentes si sus hipotenusa tienen la
misma longitud así como uno de sus
catetos de cada uno de los triángulos
entonces vamos a fijarnos en estos dos
triángulos que he pintado aquí o en
estos en este segmento este si es un
triángulo y en estos dos segmentos
verdad entonces vamos a suponer que este
de aquí pues lo con el con blanco este
lado de aquí me dice y que mide
exactamente lo mismo que este otro lado
c
ahora vamos a suponer que este lado de
aquí mide a y este otro también mi idea
así que vamos a marcarlos con doble
línea bien entonces podemos ver que la
única forma de construir este triángulo
rectángulo en realidad sólo tenemos una
forma verdad porque tenemos dos
restricciones primero tenemos que unir
estos dos puntos para que en efecto se
forme un triángulo y la otra es que este
lado que pintemos aquí debe ser
perpendicular a este lado amarillo
cierto entonces la única forma de
hacerlo es así verdad y lo tenemos es la
única forma de trazar nuestro lado que
tenga un ángulo recto y que conecte a
estos dos puntos van aquí ahí está
verdad entonces para que sea más claro
analíticamente el porque estos dos lados
verdes son congruentes usaremos el
teorema de pitágoras muy bien entonces
vamos a usar el teorema de pitágoras
vamos a fijarnos en este lado nosotros
conocemos
cuánto mide la hipotenusa y cuánto mide
este cateto verdad entonces por el
teorema de pitágoras nosotros podemos
calcular la medida de este lado
simplemente como la raíz cuadrada de se
cuadrada menos a cuadrada verdad porque
pues porque la suma de los cuadrados de
los catetos nos da el cuadrado de la
hipotenusa verdad entonces simplemente
este cateto será la raíz cuadrada de ese
cuadrado menos a cuadrada entonces esto
es digamos lo que mide este lado verde
pero si nos fijamos en este otro
triángulo también tenemos que la
hipotenusa mide ce y este cateto
mi idea así que esta misma fórmula será
válida para la longitud de este cateto
verdad y es así como obtenemos que estos
lados correspondientes estos lados
verdes tienen que ser congruentes de ahí
es que obtenemos la congruencia
hipotenusa cateto que es un caso
especial de el criterio el l
que de hecho ya habíamos mencionado
anteriormente que no se puede aplicar
general como un criterio de congruencia